[MUSIC]
Ratan, thank you so much for joining us
today.
It's an honor to speak with you.
And I know I speak for
many here in the audience when I say that
we've been looking forward to this for
question time.
>> Thank you Jones.
>> I wanted to start at the beginning of
your career.
As the Dean mentioned, you were educated
at Cornell as an architect and
a structural engineer and
planned to spend the rest of your career
in the United States.
But you returned to India, starting on the
shop floor, and
I wonder what that was like as a young man
returning from the United States to India.
>> Well, quite frankly, it was a, as much
a cultural shock.
I'd been away for ten years, and things
had changed, and
yet, they had not changed, and the
difference was quite substantive.
In addition to which I didn't return to
India to spend time on the shop floor.
So, I, I didn't really understand what was
being done,
and several times during that period of
time I thought of going back to
the US and pursuing my career as an
architect.
>> And you spent several years as the Dean
mentioned,
moving around different parts of the Tata
organization.
Were you surprised when you got the call
from your uncle in 1991 to
be chairman of, of Tata?
>> Yes I was.
Mainly because the remaining contenders
who are, not many,
handful of contenders for that position
from his own team of,
of people and it happened very suddenly
and, and
you, you begin to feel that leader he was
there for 50 plus years as chairman.
And you start to believe that somebody's
immortal and
that he's, he's going to be there
perpetually, so when he calls you and
says this is what he wants to do, it
shakes you up.
And suddenly you feel all alone.
>> Right.
And you've faced quite a formidable
challenge as the, as the Dean mentioned.
When you took over as CEO, the
organization, Tata, was large and
sprawling, with independent business
heads, that regarded their own, their own
business as their own personal fiefdoms
didn't necessarily play together well.
And you were in an economy that was
changing rapidly.
And your uncle was considered a titan of
Indian business and very large shoes for
a young CEO to fill.
How did you go about establishing your
credibility as a leader in those
early days?
>> I had, I had two, two problems.
One with, with the actual market problems
of, of a large
business house that had operated very
traditionally and, and
the other was internal to the company of,
of several titans,
if you might, who, who didn't want any
change to take place,
and I guess a certain amount of resentment
also.
So, the first five years were akin to
Clint Eastwood if you might, which,
which tended to be filled with trying to
get these elderly,
very prominent people out of, out of the
way.
It was not done with bullets.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It was done with persuasion and, and
I'm sorry to say with money.
So the first five years were spent in
creating an environment where
change was possible.
And then I've been blessed with an
organization that has been
displaying considerable spirit in wanting
to make a change.
And many things that we did had not been
done before but I, I was
always pleased to see that the response
from the organization was tremendous.
Without that, it could not have been done.
>> And one of the things that many of us
here,
as students, we study is the inertia of
organizations in the face of change.
How did you go to inspire the leaders and
the front line staff to, to believe in
the vision that you set out and some of
the changes that you wished to implement?
>> That was difficult and to some extent I
would have to humbly say that I failed.
One, one of the first promises I made
publicly was
that we'd rationalize the group and reduce
the number of businesses and
reduce the number of companies.
I often talk about the first thing that I
did with great gusto, which was to
get us out of the soaps and toiletry
business, which didn't seem to fit.
And I ran headlong into an issue of what
were we doing.
We were getting rid of a, a company that
had second and
third generation employees it was an
unheard of thing, and
who is this person who is making change
for the sake of change?
>> Right.
>> And I got attacked from all, all
quarters.
The media attacked me, the, the stock
market attacked me,
and of course there was the resentment
from within, within the,
the company as to which company would
follow now after this.
The net result was a new chairman so keen
to succeed,
and not wishing to have failure suddenly
being bombarded from all quarters.
There was no second company that got, got
sold.
>> Right.
>> And I put my tail between my legs and
and tried to look at other forms of of
growing.
>> Right.
And you've said in the past that risk is a
necessary part of a business
philosophy and certainly of your career
you've made some significant bets, and
the Dean mentioned a number of the
acquisitions.
I would also think here of the launch of
the,
the Indica Indians first indigenously
manufactured motor vehicle.
How did you get comfortable making such
consequential decisions?
And to your point, convincing others to,
to follow you into them?
>> I think convincing myself that it would
work, was, is,
is a judgement call in terms of the faith
you put in your people to do this,
in case in point was on the Indica
conventional wisdom said
that you couldn't enter the car business
without having a collaboration,
and certainly to think of designing a car
domestically and
producing it was an unheard of thing.
My friends, as we launched the car,
started to distance themselves from me.
>> [LAUGH] Right.
>> And it wasn't for me, it was to
distance themselves from failure.
>> Right.
>> And it was the trust one had
in the young, young team to put this
together that drove it.
The, the other is that from time to time,
I think change has caused a lot of people
in the company to, to
question the wisdom that such a change
would, would be based on.
>> Right.
>> And I've been lucky, and
in some cases it's been difficult, but by
and large, India is a country
that has such a great potential that
change is, by and large, well received.
>> Right.
And we've heard a lot of anxiety about the
Indian economy, and
we know that there's a lot of potential
there, but there's been recently, at
least, a lot of noise in the press about
how reform hasn't kept pace with growth.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And it's
possibly cramping India's growth
potential.
What do you think lies ahead for, for
future of India?
>> Well, you know, I, I, I've always been
very positive about the new India and
I've been saddened by the fact that after
several years
of very progressive growth there's been a
stumbling
activity that has been a country driven by
accusations of corruption.
Not wrong, rightly so.
Crony capitalism and a government that has
withdrawn its pace of, of growth.
>> Right.
>> At the same time, I, I feel that, that
has been, that has bottomed out,
and we're on a path again to grow.
But we've got to rebuild.
We've gone from an eight, 8% plus growth
rate, down to sub five briefly.
>> Right.
>> We will grow back to the growth rate we
had.
We will need to control the inflation, but
I think India will,
once again, the same spirit of the people
will make it, make it happen.
>> Right.
And one of the things that, that you
mentioned is,
that's often remarked about the Indian and
for
that matter a number of emerging markets
is this phenomenon of crony capitalism.
And you've spoken in the past about how
you value personal integrity,
both in your own leadership but in also in
the leaders you admire.
Have you ever faced an opportunity which
you had to turn down for,
for ethical reasons or for the ethical
consequences of that decision?
>> Sev, several several instances with,
where that could be so,
I think perhaps the, the most visible one
was
when we wanted to form an airline oddly
enough,
we were asked to form an airline by, by
the then prime minister.
But vested interests made,
made sure that we didn't form an airline
through three successive prime ministers.
And that was the most visible of, of the
thing which we walked away from but
because we could have probably had it by
succumbing to
subjective issues of bribery or corruption
and we walked away from it.
>> Right.
>> Where airline would have been something
we really wanted to do.
We pioneered aviation in, at the turn of
the century.
And it was emotionally something that we
would have liked very much to be in again.
>> Right.
I know both you and, and your uncle
[UNKNOWN] were both
aviation enthusiasts so, I can imagine the
disappointment that you must have felt.
One of the, one of the hallmarks of your,
your tenures here has in fact been the
move away from, from India and
transforming Tata from an India business
into a true multinational.
What's prompted the move abroad and, and
what were some of the biggest challenges
you faced in doing so?
>> To agree to extent it was the, the
issue of having the need to grow and
a need to take a view that you'd grown in
India in some cases with a fairly
substantial market share, and that as a
group we ought to look beyond the shores
of India to another economic cycle in
which we would operate.
Now that, it, it's pluses and minuses that
we didn't ever foresee that Europe would
go through the downturn that it did, and
that was where our major investments lay.
So it was a quest for growth and, and
changing the ground rules
to say that we could grow by acquisitions
which surely we had never done.
>> Right.
The international expansion though was not
without some controversy, and
aside from the economic rationale there
was also emotional consequences and
I'm thinking here of the acquisition of
Tetley Tea.
>> Yeah.
>> The idea of a beloved British tea brand
being bought by an Indian Company must
have stirred some hearts in England.
And-
>> If, if they did it was quite quiet and
dignified.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The more vocal language.
>> [LAUGH].
>> The more vocal bone was when Jaguar and
Land Rover got acquired.
>> Right.
>> And that was far more emotional and
far more visible different, different
reactions from different quarters.
Some in, some concerned that an Indian
company was going to take over
vaulted two very venerable brands what
were they going to do with it?
>> Yeah.
>> Ford had made, had not been able to
make a profit with them,
so what was this Indian company that had
no experience in the premium car segment
do with such a company?
Concerned by the workers that we were
going to close down plants and
move them to India.
And a general feeling that in England that
another British brand was gone.
>> Right.
>> Quite frankly, all we did after we got
involved was to tell the management of
the company to make their own destiny that
we'd support them in terms of
what they wanted to do.
And of course the marketplace has been a
very conducive to what we have done.
Right.
>> So I, I think the Jaguar, Land Rover
thing was much more fiery than the teeth
then there's gulp very, very quietly and
then I as said in a very dignified way.
>> And I doubt the, the British stiff
upper lip was-
>> [LAUGH].
>> What they applied there.
>> Yes.
>> One of the remarkable aspects of Tata
is its sheer complexity.
It strikes me as being an enormously
difficult challenge to be able to
manage this company day-to-day.
You have, as the Dean mentioned, almost
half a million employees worldwide,
over 100 operating companies, 36 of which
are, are publicly listed.
Dominic Barton of Mackenzie when he was
here this week spoke about great leaders
needing to have both a microscope and a
telescope that has an ability to focus on
the fine details where they really count,
but also to see the larger picture and
see the secular trends transforming their
markets.
How did you go about managing Tata day to
day and balance that need for a micro and
a macro perspective?
>> I think by and
large all our companies have had strong
CEOs that have run the businesses.
And the only,
only thing I would say is that I've had a
funny type of role where you,
you sit apart looking at the overall
company on a strategic basis.
And then when there's a problem you go
into the company much more than may
happen elsewhere in the world, where you
find yourself playing the same role
as the CEO in terms of either firefighting
or,
or moving a company in another direction
then move back again into a macro
position where you're looking at the
company or the group in its broader sense.
>> Right.
>> So it, exactly what you said, is
inadvertently has been what,
what has been done.
>> And how did you make sure that you had
the information you needed to
make the decisions?
So we've had past VFTT CEOs come in and
speak about how
they would covertly conduct visits to the
front line and, and visit factory floors,
just to get the, to gauge the spirit and
moral of their workforce.
>> I think that, that's an absolute given.
The worst thing that can happen is to, is
to determine where the company is
going through the eyes or, or the mouth of
one person, I get the CEO.
>> Right
>> Far more is gained by walking on
the shelf floor and talking to the people
and trying to communicate.
One of my weaknesses' has been I think
I've never communicated in there for
adequately with our people.
Partly because I'm, I'm a shy person, and
secondly because I didn't realize the
importance of communication,
but I think communication with the
employees is an exceedingly important
function that any company chairman has to,
has to do and be visible in that sense.
>> Did you ever have to overrule, or
disagree with decisions made by some of
the leaders of your businesses based on
information you were hearing from, from
the front lines?
>> Oh yes, yes, very much so.
And that, that's usually quite an eye
opener because you have a trusted CEO, and
you find either inadvertently or
consciously you're getting a colored
picture of, of a situation.
>> Okay.
Another one of the approaches that you
took at Tata which is a hallmark of,
of your tenure, is the focus on the bottom
of the pyramid consumer.
And we all know the story of the, the Tata
Nano and,
and, a number of us visited your factory
last year, in, in Gujarat.
And I was pleasantly surprised to find
that I could fit quite comfortably inside.
[LAUGH]
>> I'm glad you did.
>> Well I heard it was modeled after,
after you, so the-
>> [LAUGH].
>> Someone of
your stature needed to fit comfortably.
But the, the nano as we spoke about before
the interview has also met with some,
some challenges and, so I'm curious
whether you're still as
enthusiastic about the bottom of the
pyramid market today.
And what lessons did you take from the,
the nano episode?
>> Good, good question.
You know the, the Indian market,
the known consumer market's about 250 to
300 million people.
If you take the base of the pyramid and
look at, at developing products below that
and into the,
into the segment of the market that's
moving into that consuming era area,
the market size extends to 500 to 600
million people and that's a huge market.
>> Right.
>> 300 of which you don't have products to
address.
So if you can think of how to, how to
reach that, how to reach that market,
you have an exceedingly large potential
market.
And case and point might be the, the cell
phone industry in India.
When I grew up in, in school, you waited
seven to ten years to get a telephone.
There was a government incumbent company
or
government monopoly that, that had
limitations to refuse to grow.
Rates were high.
So apart from people like me a little
shopkeeper or,
or a, a handcart puller let's say,
could never dream of having connectivity
other than through a pay phone.
>> Right.
>> Today with cell phones,
it's bypassed all of that.
And, and the handcart pusher can buy
a prepaid SIM card and a low cost phone
and he's connected.
He has a number, he can be reached.
He has an identity and it's self esteem.
>> Right.
>> So you have
cell phone subscribers that are maybe 600
million in India, and
the fastest growing industry that the
country has seen.
So, it has come, because technology has
made a phone available, and
it's no longer dependent on copper wires,
or, or optical fiber.
And, and this has happened.
Again, who would have thought, ten years
ago,
that you would have 500 million telephone
subscribers in India.
So I think the potential of the Indian
market is huge
if you address yourself to, to that.
I don't think the nano adequately did
that.
And we, the lesson we learned, is you
can't do something on the basis of
trying to sell it the same way as you
would sell another car.
You should have been selling it like one
sold a scooter or a motorcycle.
And instead of two wheels,
give them four wheels and a safe form of
family transport.
So we, we learned our lessons on that and
we rectify that as, as we go forward.
>> Right, so, important profit motives,
but
also social consequences of, of really
addressing that market.
>> Yes.
>> And
Tata's a remarkable record of its
involvement with philanthropic causes, and
how do you view the role of organizations
like Tata, and in particular the role
of corporate social responsibility in
addressing needs in society?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Well I think this, this transience to
personal life also,
you got a country with tremendous
disparity of income.
You've got very rich people on the one
hand, and abject poverty on the other.
You have to be sensitive to, to the fact
that this gap cannot continue to widen
while there's a large discontented number
of people
who are looking at the inequities of, of
the environment as they see it.
To, for companies, therefore, I think
there has to be a, a sensitivity
to doing something in the, in the
communities around which you operate.
And in making an effort to, to raise the
quality of life so
that there's, there's not envy and, and
distaste for
what was there, but look, the company's
looked at in a more positive sense and
in enhancing the quality of life of the
people around them.
We expend about 4% of our net, net profit
in these rural development activities and
we do it ourselves, and
someone may argue that this is
shareholder's money, which it is.
But I think it is part a sense of, of not
just tolerance but
a sense of welcoming our companies in
wherever they've been.
And enhancing whatever we've been trying
to do in the product area or
the services area to community or being
part of the community.
>> Would you have viewed the role of
corporate social responsibility as
being quite different in the United States
versus a emerging market like India?
>> I, I don't know enough about the United
States to make
a comment but I think in one form or
another it,
it becomes an issue that all corporation
will have to, have to deal with.
And, and we had think as, as businessmen
have to consider ourselves
and removing the image of being the ugly
businessman, the venal businessman, and
being heads of, of companies and leaders
who's
interest go beyond that of their company
to the, the communities they serve.
And if I think if we can do that, we can
undo an image that has been created over
the last century of greed and, and
self-serving desires.
So, I think it's something that we need to
be sensitive about.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> So Stanford has a reputation for
entrepreneurship, and
many of the students here in the crowd
have aspirations to be entrepreneurs.
Do you think the innovation taking place
in emerging markets is going to
be driven more by multinationals like
Tata?
Or do individual entrepreneurs have the
ability to disrupt major markets in,
in India and others like it?
>> I would hope that it's the latter.
I would hope that we can home grow
enterprises in, in various countries.
I think what the United States has had,
which is very different,
is its had a an environment where a good
idea driven by
people of merit has a better chance of
being supported and financed and,
and nurtured than you might find in, in
developed countries.
Very often a good idea dies in, in a
developed country or even, I mean
a developing country or even a developed
country outside the United States.
And, and that person finally moves to the
United States, and makes a success.
And it's because the environment allows
that to happen.
So I think there's a need for an, a
supporting environment to take place, but
I would hope that we would see more and
more local companies being
entrepreneurial and creative and, and
being, at some stage, global player.
>> Right.
And certainly we've seen a number of
countries try to replicate the success of
Silicon Valley and have found that it
takes a unique mix of ingredients.
>> Yeah.
>> Whether it's human capital,
legal institutions and so on.
Are you hopeful that India will be able
to,
to create that dynamic within its own
country?
>> I think the potential exists.
Now whether India does or doesn't will
depend, unfortunately, to a much greater
extent on, on government policy than it
does in a totally free environment.
>> I mention when you took over that many,
many external observers there thought
you had large shoes to fill in taking over
from your uncle.
Now, with another transition of power,
Cyrus Pallonji Mistry has his own large
shoes to fill, that of yourself.
I wonder what advice you would give Cyrus,
as he takes,
takes on his task as chairman?
>> I've told Cyrus that he needs to be his
own person.
that, finally, it was something I did.
I, I realized the shoes I had to fill were
far too big for
me to mimic the person I wa, I was
following.
And I just decided that just being myself
and
do what I thought was right would be the
way to go.
I've told Cyrus the same thing.
I think he, he should feel that he is
being his own person and
let his personality and his conscience, if
you might, drive him.
>> In a moment I'm going to turn it over
to the audience for, for questions.
But one last question before we do.
In Stanford we ask one question of all our
applicants to the MBA program, which is,
what matters most to you and why?
I wonder how you'd answer that question.
[LAUGH].
>> I'd obviously fail at Stanford,
because I don't know how I can answer that
question.
I, to me I think short term the transition
of suddenly having a lot of time and
being able to be the master of that time
is, is a lovely luxury.
Whether that luxury becomes boredom as
time goes on, is
something that will need to be seen, and
how it gets filled with other pursuits.
As head of the Trust, I, I will be
involved in some of the things we've
talked about in the past few minutes, of
trying to make a difference in,
in what in the quality of life of the
people in, in India.
But to what extent, my next few years will
lead,
lead me to fulfill that or change from
that view, I don't know.
So, with humility, I'd have to say, I
wouldn't volunteer the success
mode the Stanford graduate would in
answering your question.
>> Well, I think of a lifetime of, of
service that we,
we can draw any conclusions to.
Some of the things that have clearly
mattered to
you in terms of the impact that you've had
on, on Indian society.
>> I think if, if, I think seriously if I
said I
would like to be seen as someone who could
continue to try to make a difference,
I think that would be a very satisfying
thing for me to achieve.
>> I think that's a great point to, to
turn it over to questions.
>> A question we have been struggling with
in some of our classes is
the role that large companies have in
creating macro change, and
you're clearly doing that in India.
I'm wondering if you, if you have any
anecdotes of ways in which you've been
able, by your position, to influence the
government to make certain decisions that
were in the best interest of the country
when maybe they wouldn't have?
>> Your, your question relates to how we
are, how we are channeling or
deciding how, how and where to channel our
funds in, in that sense, or?
>> Al, almost the, the influence that a
large business, large business that is,
that has a vision for, for good for
the country can have in changing or
influencing policy, pol positively?
>> I, I think I don't know if I'm
answering your
question adequately but I think large
business has,
has to have an element of, of orienting
themselves to,
to serve a social need also in addition to
just serving a business need.
And in our case, I think we that may be
driven by, by business motivation,
but we're, we should always be conscious
of,
of areas that we feel are not in the
public interest.
And now going into dangerous waters, but
we withdrew from activities in the, in the
liquor business,
because we felt that this was an area that
tended to be
serving a consumer base that we, that
perhaps, we didn't want to be.
We, we looked very hard about being in, in
certain natural resource business,
which, which had become rather venal in
terms of how those businesses were run.
And I think similarly, we've entered
businesses may be small,
in a small way, which have been what we
considered to be a worthwhile
thing to do for the communities that we've
been in, but
I don't think there's, there's been an, an
open and a, and
a very constructive way to do what you've,
what you've suggested as here.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Thank you, Phil, thank, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]